お風呂上がりです。はじめしゃちょーです。
はいというわけでちょうど2週間前ぐらいかな
僕は
動画で
宣言していました
遊戯王の
世界たいさい・・・
はぁ
ごめんちょっと本当に緊張がほぐれてもぉぉぉぉぉぉ
緩く行きますね今日は
今日は緩くいかせてくれ‼
遊戯王カードの世界大会予選
ＷＣＳ２０１８の予選が始まって
僕は‼
2週間前の動画で
必ず予選を勝つと・・・
・・・言った気がします
2月中も大会はまだまだあるんで
もうちょっと、頑張っていきます！
次こそぉ
勝つぞぉ‼(アホらしく)
おっと・・・
言ってませんでしたね
2月18日
え～無事
予選大会
優勝してきましたあああああああああああああ！
あああああああああ？
あああああああああああ！
優勝商品です
プレイマット
はぁい！
終わったぁ！
終わったァァァァァァ
いやこっからなんですけどね
こっからなんですよ
5月6月に県の代表を決める大会があるんで
まぁ部活で言う県大会ですね
県大会があるんで
まぁそれに向けて頑張りたいんですけども
ひとまず
僕は１、２ヶ月大会に出る必要がない
いや本当によかったよもぉぉぉ
なによりもさぁ動画で言っちゃったから
プレッシャーがすごかったんすよね
去年優勝したから今年も優勝しないと
まじおまえ
まぐれで勝ったじゃんみたいになるんで
２年連続出来たんで
おっとそれ以上言わないでおこう
はい、というわけで無事勝てました…
ちょっと見ます！？
遊戯王の大会の雰囲気を
どんな感じかわかんない人多いと思うんで
見て見ましょう
どうぞ
はい、というわけでこんな感じですね
もう
なんだろうな
あの決して一緒にしてるわけじゃないんですけど
もう囲碁と将棋の大会みたいな雰囲気がすごい
続いております…
もうこれずーっと
相手の方が考えてますね
スカイピースのじんたんみたいな人でした！
しぃっしぃ
まじでね、もうね
あれだよもう
将棋と囲碁っすよ
どんだけ先を読んでも
展開をかんがえるかとか
何を出してどうなるかが
ずっと考えなきゃいけないんで
めちゃくちゃ頭使うんすよね
相手が悩んでますね
しぃっし
俺もこれねぇ普通の顔してるんですけど
心の中だと
「やべぇどうしようなにもできねぇ(ドキドキ)」
って思ってるかもしれんですけど
そこをポーカーフェイスで誤魔化すというのも
テクニックの一つです。
ほら相手がずっと手札見て考えてますね
おっなんかメモ取りました。
ヒントになるようなことは全部メモしてます僕は
もうとりあえず勝ちゃいいんで勝ちゃ
どうすか？俺のポーカーフェイス
いやぁ悩みますよ。本当に悩みます
決勝戦まで来た時点でもう
すごいことだしぃ
普通の顔してますけど、
下で足ガックガクに震えてて
もう手とか冷え切ってますからね